I think about the things that I know
that you're going to do that you think
you're not and you don't think that
you're gonna be on snapchat and I know
you're going to be so one thing I'm
loving right now is everybody in Josh um
and I'm talking to you like Gary
discovered snapchat recently that's
right I have turned into a 13 year old
girl while I've been away on vacation
and I am now a snapchat Queen a lot of
young entrepreneurs asking me what
advice I'd give them and my answer is
patience so all about the snapchat
I [ __ ] be fun to put a couple clips
together from the Chase Jarvis interview
I gave in 2013 I would tell you if I'm a
photographer right now the number one
place I would build an audience on
number one is snapchat let me explain
why the reality is is that snapchat is
the one place that you can almost
guarantee consumption because the
picture disappears people actually click
it and look at it for those eight
seconds where's its Twitter and Facebook
you'll see everything you're just going
for you to quickly weird snapchat you
actually give that photo oh by the way
you give it those 7 10 11 seconds if I'm
a photographer the ability for me to
take a photo and then send it to my
snapchat audience and actually have it
consumed and right on top of it unless
you're a purist at it you know but the
truth is that to me is a place where
they need to be paying attention to and
a little talk a game and lay web as well
not so sure it was snapshots on snapchat
well actually I think right now snapchat
is one of the most successful marketing
tools for me personally with my brand
everybody worries about width right like
everybody cares about top-line numbers
impressions followers people care about
dumb [ __ ] data what snapchat is doing
everybody is very simple it's not about
how many impressions you get it's how
much attention you get I don't care what
anybody in this room does or watching at
home on livestream the number one thing
we all have to do is tell our story to
somebody along the path of them making a
decision before you tell your story you
have to have somebody's attention and
what snapchat does is it gives you the
attention snapchat is a communication
funnels that for those nine seconds
while you're holding it you actually
have to pay attention which is why it's
important and once it evolves the way
Facebook evolved and becomes older
there'll be an opportunity for you can
you figure out how to tell a story in an
8-second picture or text over it it
disappears this is me talking about
snapchat in 2013 this is not a 2016
phenomenon for me and and there's a
little bit of like yeah I mean let's
call what it is I love the I told you so
kind of video and that's what this is
[Music]